I want to show you the story from CNN
business and I want to give a special
shout out to one of the most evil people
in media Brian stelter yes CNN writes
this article these four words are
helping spread vaccine misinformation
four little words do your own research
are hurting the U.S pandemic response
CNN's Chief media correspondent Brian
stelter said on reliable sources now
this story is from last month but I
think it's very important because Brian
Selter also had a segment where he said
don't go and watch the propaganda come
to us
that's how you know you're being lied to
because I tell you this make sure you go
and watch CNN you understand their point
of view make sure you're watching you
know progressives and conservatives so
you get a healthy diet of perspective
and then figure out what you think is
right for you why I'm not an
authoritarian and I think most of the
people come on the show some people are
authorities but most people aren't and
so what that means is it's up to you to
figure out what works for you and what
you believe CNN is authoritarian they
are evil they want to keep you in the
dark so that you serve them they
literally told you reading Wikileaks was
illegal yeah I remember they literally
came out on National Television for us
because we're journalists but but
he has a law degree exactly well it's
like the first amendment thing remember
that famous thing where he's like who
said a protest needs to be peaceful and
then Ramen bro was just like it's right
there in the First Amendment you gotta
look it up listening and believing are
different and you want to listen with
skepticism to as much as you can Jacinda
Arden is she the prime minister of uh or
New Zealand New Zealand we are your only
source of Truth yeah yeah this is like
from a week ago a video of her on
Twitter I saw it's so disturbing that
she's telling people do not listen to
these other sources do not pay attention
to them we are only listen to us we are
the something happened to the like the
sort of wealthy white liberal mind right
I I don't know why that is but like you
know I basically I look at Australia and
New Zealand and I'm like this is what it
would be like if the wealthy white
liberals were running were completely in
control of this country right if the
Democratic party didn't have you know a
big part of its constituency is like
minorities like if it were just white
Democrats we would be like Australia and
New Zealand yup guarantee it yep so uh
we can every day just um you know give
your respects to the right wing nut jobs
living in the mountains for helping keep
this country uh balanced I guess I'm
kidding by the way but I mean we do have
it a lot better than other places like
you know some people often are like man
this I've seen something like America's
gone crazy I'm like if you want to see
crazy like there are there are much
worse places to be it was so crazy what
she said to an American well check us
out we have it we have it here in
America Lydia just pulled this article
up from the New York Times don't go down
the rabbit hole hold on hold on get
ready for this critical thinking as we
are taught to do it isn't helping in the
fight against misinformation
please okay Brian Selter is telling
people don't do your own research the
New York Times is saying don't think
critically
all right
it's like Ethan Klein said you don't
even have to think about it you just go
on the website and it tells you what to
do congratulations well they want little
peasant slaves and they're doing the pr
bidding of the ruling establishment that
wants to control them more and have
every uh aspect of their lives carefully
coordinated in a way that directly
benefits them this is exactly what
they're doing sophisticated yeah they're
sophisticated people well they think
they could fool everyone and they have
absolute disrespect for the general
public that's why they lie to them
continually that's why they're they're
pushing this other nonsense onto people
and you know for some people uh they're
not wrong but for the majority of people
uh I I believe they're totally wrong and
a lot of people saying hey they're
telling me not to do my own homework
they're telling me not to do my own
research they're telling me not to
critically think look to be fair when
they say not to do your own research
they're helping you because as we know
it would be illegal right you know Chris
Cuomo it was Cuomo said that yeah we can
look at these documents because we're
journalists see now what if you went you
did your own research and you broke the
law Luke don't think critically well
just go to the just go to the
government's website the FBI hasn't
trapped people for Less
um already so that you know maybe you're
not even wrong to be honest with you but
but again this just shows you that
that's the complete
PR representation that the media really
is they're not journalists they're not
the mainstream media they're just
spokespersons for the super rich that
are trying to placate you pacify you and
make you comply with every crazy demand
that they have for you maybe some value
if they had rephrases and said like
don't believe everything you read at
face value look deeper no no no no do
critical thinking maybe then it would
make if they had the opposite message of
what they had now maybe then you can
make an argument you're telling people
to think critically of course you're
telling them they're telling people to
do the opposite either there not to
either they're idiotically conflating
the the the definition of thinking
critically and don't believe everything
you see at face value or they're
blatantly attempting to mislead people
to because Slaughter maybe Ian is is a
secret establishment shell because of
course I know because well well look I'm
gonna say this but I'm being fair you
are post-modernist and you often placate
the things they're doing and try to find
justifications as if they're doing
something good uh 2006 I started making
YouTube videos they contacted me October
2006. that's a joke by the way
I mean post-modernism has a way to
critique all this stuff like once you
understand what they're doing like you
start you start reading you know
Foucault is like one of the classic
Lefty thinkers but a big part of
Foucault's work is about biopolitics
like the management of a human
population's health that seems really
relevant right about now honestly I went
through a hard post-modernist phase
where I started to think like that from
like 2006 to 2008 and it's there's video
evidence of it if you want to watch it
on YouTube it was pretty crazy but
having gone through it I can now see the
pitfalls as if I'm experiencing what
they're experiencing it helps and
sometimes I'll bring that up on the show
and it's really kind of out of place on
this show because we're talking more
about like literology you know people
don't understand too I think I think
we'll we can do the big you know reveal
uh Ian actually you know he normally
wears a suit I'm taking my shirt off he
normally he normally wears a suit and he
walks around with his hair done up very
properly and he's got a British accent I
do two hours we hired an actor and we
were like we need a hippie Stoner you
know
um thanks for doing my makeup beforehand
too yeah by the way it's just dirt
It's a wig
I don't know how much longer we'll uh
will will last in this world right in
politics well look what happens with
Stephen Crowder yeah he doesn't a comedy
bit on a news story and they come after
him and now there's a big story he can't
talk about and you know censorship is
real we set up we we may have uh you
know timcast.com and we're working
really hard we're growing freedomastan
is now um in in the in the ownership of
the Tim cast media
growing conglomerate which means we're
going to be doing more culture content
more gun content we're going to be
having like range stuff training and you
know maybe even some CQC training stuff
uh so we're growing we're definitely
growing and we want we want to teach
people responsibility we want to inspire
people to to take care of themselves to
think critically
but
you know we're still walking on thin ice
we're still traversing you know flaming
field at any moment we could be you know
cut back severely it could make it very
very difficult to try and defend our
ideals and our our vision I think of it
as a metaphor of like we're streaming
swimming upstream and that's the
political situation we're all trying to
swim upstream together then when we get
to the where we're going that's there's
all these other fish there and this is
the culture and we're all kind of
competing to get through but then
there's the Gate of the dam and that's
the technology that we use and unless we
control the technology that we're using
there's no way to get up through that
Dam to get Upstream any further
it's not just technology in its
infrastructure right so the technology
that's being built out with the the
metaverse project I think you've been
calling it is it's infrastructure
creating Pathways for people to maintain
Communications to persist as the likes
of CNN the New York Times try to curtail
your ability to think or or literally
tell you not to and those are the people
promoted those are the people in the in
the algorithms those are the people in
your news feed those are the people you
get notifications from even if you don't
follow them other independent voices
that question that that try to have a
debate here that try to counter The
Narrative that try to enter the
conversation from a point of view that's
not from the script well they get hit
with fake news accusations so this is
the world that we're living in more and
more and their their message is becoming
more and more radical I mean telling
people I mean if you're at a point where
you're a media institution and your main
headline is don't critically think like
that's when you know you're not a part
of the good guys that's when you know
you're not doing journalism that's when
you no you're not a reporter you're a
repeater for the special billionaire
globalist class that that directly calls
the shots that pays the bills that
influences our politics more than we
could even imagine but let's let's also
um you know wrap this segment up on a
high note
if if
the fact that we're here having this
conversation and highlighting it is
proof that Victory is not only possible
but our mere existence and the success
of this show and you know the work you
do with human events and Luke your
channel it's proof that victory has been
happening these are these are battles we
win every day with all the work that
we're doing and for everybody watching
as well supporting the work and I mean
you think about like vaccine mandates
right six months ago they were saying oh
of course we're not going to have
mandate vaccines right they were just
relying on persuasion and then six
months later they're mandating them
that's that's if properly viewed that's
a loss right that's an admission a
concession of defeat like you were not
able to persuade people and with your
methods of persuasion and so you
resorted to government Force and and
like in so many other ways right the
major media corporate media has gone
from we're not worried about these
competitors we are not you know we are
better at our jobs we are more accurate
people are ultimately like some small
Fringe number of people are going to
rely on crazies but like most people
will rely on us and they've also given
that up they're like oh actually we've
lost that battle too so now we need to
like lean on the social media platforms
and get them to shut up our competition
yep yep and when we see them try and use
extreme force against parents I gotta
say it a lot of this we we may look I'll
I'll say this I may fear that you know
who knows how long until they try and
you know take out our Channel or
whatever you know or delete it but I I
will say there's a lot of indicators
that they're they're struggling and
they're panicking and I mean
establishment forces that's this major
corporations that's Republicans it's
Democrats they they are they are
struggling to maintain some kind of
control when you're going after satire
when you're going after a comedy when
you're going after memes I mean that's
acts of desperation I mean this is what
happened in Soviet level communist
countries this is what happened to you
know my family in Poland they made sure
that that musicians comedy performers uh
poets those are the first people that
the Soviet Union went after because they
influenced culture they influenced the
general public in a way that motivated
them through ART and if I'm ever proud
of anything I'm definitely proud of my
t-shirt store I'm definitely proud of my
ideas I'm proud of my email list that's
very hard to take away because I have a
physical copy of it I'm very proud of my
members area because this is something
that I've been creating and now that
they're going after our art it's truly
the last kind of sign of total you know
I don't want to be hyperbolic I don't
want to be too Sensational but but we're
reaching the point of absurdity we're
reaching the point that I believe is
sort of dangerous because they're
literally trying to hit anything that
even goes against their uh cult that
even goes against their larger ideology
that goes against any kind of prevailing
uh ideas that they want to throw at you
so so this is absurd I think it's
definitely going to get worse this is a
symbols of a very insecure dangerous
Empire that uh because of that
insecurity is there there's the danger
and that's something to really look out
when you say you think it'll only get
worse what exactly do you think well
when you have such security when you
have such fear by the state that they
literally have to hit satire comedy art
and and run attack pieces on anyone who
goes against them look what's happening
Kyrie Irving he's being attacked
viciously he just came out with a
statement today saying it's it's not
about money it's about Freedom
um and and and he's he's making a very
important stand here but everyone in the
establishment every Sports commentator
is regurgitating the same lines against
them the same talking points they should
shut up and dribble right pretty much
yeah yeah pretty much that's the points
that they're making a whole bunch of
white people telling a black man to shut
up and dribble yeah yeah I think it's
funny right was it who said that first
Laura Ingram
I talk about LeBron right yeah I think
the difference is and we mentioned this
the other day is that LeBron was opining
on politics that had nothing to do with
his game whereas Kyrie Irving is saying
like they're not letting me play unless
I submit to this and I'm not going to do
it yeah so you're very different sir it
seems like the Republicans have the
opportunity to be like the ultimate
workers rights party I I don't want to
say to a stupid comment from from uh
Ingram yeah like yeah oh yeah no like
look you know I kind of I feel like the
last you know five years there have been
moments where you're like okay that was
kind of dumb right like you and you look
back at sort of two 2010 era GOP
behavior and you're like eh not not the
greatest like that's kind of tacky
especially when they you know sort of
demean workers and laud like corporate
people you know um when I when I was
talking talking to Charlie Kirk about a
lot of these issues he says he said you
know the conservatives weren't ready for
these things talking about like populist
ideas in the working class not not the
working class specifically but there's a
lot of things where he was like we
didn't realize this like the
corporations and stuff like that and I'm
just thinking like
I uh Jack Murphy mentioned that when the
Republican Party said okay to gay
marriage that allowed him to be like
okay I can I can Embrace this party
right now I actually feel like what's
happening is the Republican party has
shifted to the left thanks to Donald
Trump a lot of independent voters were
like he's the guy I'm gonna vote for
because his politics are lying closer
with mine populism fighting back against
the establishment less so with with
traditional conservative conservatism or
anything like that so now I I see you
know in this battle there's a more
moderate right concerned about what's
going on I think that builds a bigger
Coalition and more optimism I suppose I
think so too and I mean there's there's
some Democrats who are ringing the alarm
Bell I mean something I guess I should
have brought up for discussion is
there's this op-ed or about this guy
David Shore who was on Obama's polling
team and he's like a socialist but he's
one of these people who's like hardcore
or poor analyst reader and he's like
ringing the alarm Bells at Democrats
because he's like hey guys Donald Trump
is really good for the Republican party
as a general matter because he
reoriented their policy position
and their their base to give them huge
structural advantages in the Senate and
the Electoral College and like basically
he's like we need to radically restruct
you know we need to add States we need
to do all these crazy things in order to
win
um but like when Democrats are saying
that the point is like yeah Republicans
are you know I'm this is why I'm not
black filled at all like you know if if
we can get past social media censorship
and some of the other Shenanigans
Republicans have a much more popular
policy platform than they did 10 years
ago but you know what's really funny if
you look at the polling data the
Democratic party mostly likes the
Democratic party the Republican voter
mostly dislikes the Republicans are you
that's amazing it's certain it is funny
that way it's like they're just you know
maybe eventually these congressmen will
will finally kind of rotate out we We
There is a record number of people
running is my understanding for in the
Republican uh right in the races for the
Republican primaries and for congress so
I'm just saying too many Republicans
running is actually bad news for the
Republicans but too many Republicans
running in the prime Mary's is really
good news yeah that's what needs to
happen yeah and I mean also without you
know any sort of suicide pact type stuff
like I mean again I'm going back to like
Linwood being like don't vote for the
Georgia Senate candidates do you see you
see that lie they put out there like
Donald Trump told people not to vote no
that was Lynnwood it's it's insane the
story just came out daily basically
reporting that Trump said that if they
don't something if they don't like sort
through the fraud then Republicans won't
be voting in 2022 or 2024. he didn't say
not to vote he was expressing his
opinion that people wouldn't have trust
in the elections and wouldn't come out
yeah I I don't know I I've you know I'll
again be I really am kind of annoyed by
comments like that because Trump was
President he was he was empowered he had
the ability to do some stuff now he's
not right yeah like you know if you want
to blame anybody for like not getting
the stuff done that needed to be done
before the election blame yourself like
you were you that was your job not to be
too nihilistic but I don't think we
could vote our way out of this mess
personally myself that's just my my
opinion it might be to black pill for
some people but I do think it's going to
be art it's going to be culture it's
going to be memes it's going to be ideas
it's going to be individuals standing up
for their personal individual liberties
and being personally responsible for
themselves moving away from from such a
Draconian totalitarian system and
deciding that they're going to be taking
care of themselves by being happy
healthy and productive as much as they
can and I think the reason that the
state thrives off of so many people who
don't think people who are unhealthy
it's motivated in a way where you not
being fulfilled you being weak makes the
state stronger so I think if anything's
going to happen if there's ever going to
be a change it's citizenry deciding to
take care of themselves take personal
responsibility be happy healthy and
prosperous and that will eventually
reverberate and reciprocate into people
moving away from the state and moving
towards their own kind of individual
liberty yeah you pointed out if we can
overcome the tech censorship then yeah
and I yeah I think that's a big one
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time